most actors will eventually find
themselves
locking lips with another actor who in
real life
has nothing to do with them romantically
sometimes
these kisses have little to no
consequences but other times
on-screen kisses can get actors in
trouble
in real life in 1995
star trek deep space nine aired what
proved to be
one of the most controversial episodes
of the entire franchise
jadzia dax takes center stage and season
four is rejoined where she's reunited
with lenara khan
dax and lanara are joined trill who
share their existence
with slug-like symbians that carry their
memories
and experiences from host to host over
the course of centuries
with their respective previous hosts
ducks and lenara were once married
however it's forbidden for joined trill
to become involved with romantic
partners from previous
lifetimes so when they kiss it
definitely has consequences
this happened to be the case in the real
world as well
dax actress terry farrell and the makers
of ds9
faced a lot of backlash for the kiss in
the star trek
deep space nine companion book producer
ronald d
moore said one of their southern
affiliates took the show off the air
while another producer steve oster said
he received
plenty of calls complaining about the
episode
in the 2018 documentary what we left
behind
farrell seems more than content with her
part in the episode
saying still to this day people come up
to me and say
thank you sadie sync entered the cast of
stranger things in the show's
second season as max eventually becoming
part of the team of young heroes
investigating all the crazy stuff going
on in hawkins indiana
while dustin holds a torch for max for
most of the season
it's lucas who shares a first kiss with
her in that season's finale
on the face of it there didn't appear to
be anything particularly controversial
about the kiss
but that changed once enough fans caught
an episode of the after show series
beyond stranger things there sync
revealed her kiss with lucas
wasn't originally in the script and she
didn't know about it
until the day the scene was filmed ross
duffer
one of stranger things's showrunners
apparently jokingly told sync that it
was her fault
the kiss was at it duffer had previously
chatted sync about having her kiss lucas
and according to sync duffer said the
fact that she was quote
so freaked out by the idea is what
inspired him to
add the scene you reacted so strongly to
this i was just joking
and you just went you were so freaked
out that i was like well i gotta make
her do it now
a lot of fans expressed rage over the
story
due in no small part to it coming to
light around the same time
as the metoo movement in the wake of the
controversy
sync backtracked a bit telling the rap i
mean
of course i was nervous but i never
objected to it
or felt pushed into anything billy bob
thornton
and angelina jolie met in 1999 on the
set of the dramedy pushing tin
in spite of a 20-year age difference
they married in 2000.
however their marriage ended with
divorce in 2003.
according to thornton the main reason
they ultimately didn't work as a couple
was their different
lifestyles in 2018 he told hfpa
in conversation hers is a global
lifestyle
and mine is an agoraphobic lifestyle so
that's really that's the only reason
we're probably not still together
besides this thornton said one of the
more memorable stresses on the marriage
was his explicit scene with halle berry
in the 2001 romantic drama
monsters ball thorden explained to
speaking to the sun how filming monsters
ball made things tough
she is one of the most beautiful women
in the world and i am talking on the
phone to my wife and she says
what have you been doing today other
people's situations are hard
with areas of doubt but if you are a
thousand miles from home on a film set
simulating sex with a beautiful woman
it's even tougher
decades after its 1971 release
the dark comedy herald and mod is
considered a classic
but the film wasn't so well regarded
when it hit theaters
and it helps steer the career trajectory
of its male lead
to unwanted destinations harold and mod
is about a death-obsessed man in his
early 20s who drives a hearse
stages bizarre fake suicides for fun and
regularly attends the funerals of people
he's never met
it's at one of these funerals that
harold meets the elderly mod
who likewise goes to funeral services as
a hobby
the two become lovers a notion that
didn't sit well
with audiences the guardian reported
that charles mulvihill
one of the film's producers told peter
biskind that no one
wanted to see these characters kiss you
couldn't drag people in
the idea of a 20 year old boy with an 80
year old woman just made people want
to vomit bud court said kissing ruth
gordon on the screen was both quote
a blessing and a curse professionally
speaking
he was typecast right away and only
offered what he called
weirdo roles he turned them all down
including the role of billy bibbitt
ultimately played by brad doreth in one
flew over the cuckoo's nest
on the other hand court expressed pride
in helping bring harold
and maude to life he told the guardian
he made
lasting friendships on the set of the
film including with gordon
in how i met your mother jason siegel
got in trouble for kissing co-star
alison hannigan
who played his wife lily for two reasons
first because kissing him bothered
hannigan and second
because it put him in debt to her siegel
was a smoker when the show began
production and hannigan isn't a fan of
kissing smokers
she told digital spy in 2008
i cannot stand cigarette smoke she said
kissing seagull was quote
like kissing an ashtray clarifying that
he did use things
such as mints to mask the taste hannigan
explained that seagull tried to use her
distaste of smoking as motivation to
quit
when we started the pilot for how i met
your mother he was like
get me to stop smoking i'll be your best
friend
so we did this bet where he would owe me
10
every time he had a cigarette after the
first day
he owed me 200 hannigan recalls that
seagull
succeeded in giving up cigarettes for a
while but that he started smoking
again when under stress thankfully it
doesn't seem like the butts
stopped the pair from remaining friends
when they appeared together on the talk
during the lead up to the how i met your
mother finale hannigan
openly wept at the idea of not working
with siegel anymore
tommy davidson claimed in his 2020
memoir living in color what's funny
about me
that kissing jada pinkett smith while
filming the 1999 romantic comedy woo
almost got him into a fist fight with
her husband
will smith according to his memoir
neither he
nor his co-star were happy with how the
film ended
so davidson said he pitched the idea
that actually wound up
being the film's finale with him and
jada pinkett smith dancing in the middle
of a city street
but while davidson and smith had agreed
on the new ending
davidson added something without letting
jada know first
when they filmed the scene davidson
kissed her without
warning davidson says as soon as the
scene was done filming
an enraged will smith followed him into
his trailer
where things nearly got violent if a
black man that matters you from philly
yeah and come at you you best be ready
thankfully for everyone involved the
actress stepped in and calmed things
down between her husband
and her co-star davidson says that he
and smith remain good friends to this
day
william shatner doesn't enjoy the best
reputation
in terms of how he treats his co-stars
but there's at least one scene in star
trek the original series that shatner
michelle nichols
and anyone else involved should be proud
of no matter what former colleagues
say of them in the 1968 star trek
episode
plato's stepchildren airing only a year
after the us supreme court deemed
interracial marriage legal
shatner and nichols treated audiences to
the first kiss between
black and white actors on scripted tv in
the scene
shatner's captain kirk and nichols
lieutenant uhura
are forced to kiss each other by a group
of aliens who style themselves after the
ancient greeks
in her 1994 memoir beyond uhura
nichols wrote that nbc wasn't happy when
they learned of the kissing scene and a
deal was struck between the network
and star trek's producers that two
scenes would be filmed
one in which kirk and uhura kissed and
one in which they
didn't not wanting the kissless scene to
air
shatner and nichols purposely bungled
them so they wouldn't be usable
while nbc was worried the episode
wouldn't play well in the south
nichols shatner and the rest of the cast
and crew were disappointed by a very
different
locale's reaction plato's stepchildren
joined a list of 4 star trek the
original series episodes the bbc refused
to air
until 1994. the british broadcaster's
official reason for banning the episode
however
was the sadism displayed by the
episode's villains rather than the
interracial kiss
in season 3 of the crime anthology
series fargo
ewan mcgregor pulls double duty as twin
brothers emmett
and rey stussy emmett is a successful
businessman
and rey is a down on his luck parole
officer the conflict between the
brothers gets heated
after rey falls for one of his parolees
nikki
played by mary elizabeth winstead she
convinces rey that his brother owes him
more than he's given
at first you might get the impression
nikki is using rey
for her own benefit but it soon becomes
clear her feelings for him are genuine
it apparently wasn't
too difficult for winstead to act like
she loved rey stussy because
it wouldn't be too long before mcgregor
and winstead would become a couple
in spite of both being married when they
met
on the set while we don't know exactly
when their relationship
started it seems clear that working
together on fargo had something to do
with it
in may 2017 a month after fargo's
season 3 finale winstead announced her
breakup with husband riley stearns
and in early 2018 mcgregor filed for
divorce from his wife
of 22 years after mcgregor and winstead
were spotted kissing in public
people claimed that an unnamed source
said the pair had been involved
since winstead's separation in november
2017
star trek discovery featured the first
kiss between two men
in the franchise in the episode into the
forest i go
paul stamets nearly dies when he uses
his body to perform 133 consecutive
warps with discovery's spore drive
in order to give the crew the edge they
need over the klingon ship
the sarcophagus if we can save pavo
defeat the klingons and do all this
133 jumps it is after the battle is won
stamets agrees to one more jump to a
federation starbase
on his way to make the jump he finds his
husband
dr hugh culber and gives him a loving
kiss before assuring him that after he's
done
they'll be taking a long vacation actors
wilson cruz and anthony rapp
predictably faced a backlash from part
of the audience
in an eloquent and cutting facebook post
cruz
let those fans know he wasn't going to
be made to feel guilty for a kiss
i'm not here for your comfort that's not
why we are here
we are here to grow star trek is and has
always been here to challenge
you to look outside of yourself and to
see other people and
other experiences in yourself in at
least
one case it wasn't so much an on-screen
kiss that got an actor in trouble as
much as it was an avoided kiss that
helped to tank a movie
in spite of superstars johnny depp and
angelina jolie
in the lead roles for the 2010 romantic
thriller the tourist
critics panned the flick one of the more
recurring criticisms
leveled against the film is the lack of
chemistry between its romantic leads
including kissing scenes that failed to
excite anyone
a story that leaked about a month before
the tourist's release
may provide a hint as to what went wrong
in november 2010 the daily mail reported
that
audiences would be cheated out of a
steamy shower scene between depp
and jolie according to their source when
depp's longtime girlfriend
vanessa parade learned of the sequence
she reportedly
begged depp to pull out of the film depp
refused to quit the movie but he gave
parade the concession that he would
demand the shower scene be scrapped it's
only speculation but
considering what depp was willing to do
to placate parody's jealousy
it doesn't feel like a stretch to wonder
whether or not this
impacted his overall performance in the
film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you